a twitch streamer reached diamond and
apex legends using only his mouth with
the goal to reach masters rocky no hands
has made a name for himself not only in
apex but literally every game that he
takes on
all right everyone before we get into
the video i have to remind you as always
to hit the like button the subscribe
button and to ring the notification bell
so if you don't know who rocky no hands
is he's a content creator signed with
luminosity he holds multiple guinness
world records and is an all-around cool
dude he also calls himself the oral
assassin because he plays games using
only his mouth and recently he just
pulled off the incredible by reaching
diamond 2 and apex legends by using
again just his mouth rocky got into an
accident in 2006 when he was dropped
landed on his head and broke his neck
became paralyzed from the chest down
rocky explains to me that he reached
this rank by solo queuing or queuing
with his brother and random so he wasn't
carried here it's just absolute raw
skill
[Music]
they don't call me the greatest for
nothing baby and he's still making
progress and moving up in the ranks
rocky told me that there are physical
limitations to what he is able to
achieve with movement which is known to
be insanely difficult in apex his
descriptor was that he wouldn't be able
to do certain things with movement like
the pros despite this he's been able to
climb the ranks just due to his raw
skill in 2022 rocky's built up a loyal
following of fans who love his content
he said that most people who watch his
videos or streams don't realize that his
gameplay comes from him just using his
mouth usually the first thing they say
is like i didn't even realize that you
were playing with your mouth i was
watching the video
and then uh you know the watch like the
second time like oh crap this guy's
using his mouth that's amazing rocky
plays video games with the controller
known as a quad stick being paralyzed
from the neck down after the accident
rocky is unable to use a controller so
the quastic enables him to play games
that he wants to play basically just one
analog with uh three holes in it that
you can
dip or puff into the holes and you could
like sip into one of them two of them
three of them at the same time and then
there's a lip trigger at the bottom that
also acts as a button the quad stick is
able to be purchased online with
different kinds available all compatible
with different systems lately rocky has
been in the news after he hit diamond 3
and apex legends which makes sense
because apex legends is literally one of
the most technically demanding games out
there apex has been renowned since its
release for the combination of movement
strategy and gunplay skills it requires
and balancing all that at a high level
with only your mouth is truly an
accomplishment i mean right now i'm
halfway through d3
and apex
which i only play for like three hours a
day
um from like two to five and then i hop
on stream and play elder rings so i only
play like three hours a day and i'm at
uh d3 i should get to d2 eventually here
hopefully
but uh
no one else in the world has ever done
that you know what i mean like that's
not something that
um anyone's like accomplished or
even you know
came close to but as he described rocky
doesn't stick to just apex on stream
he's also played a bunch of warzone
fortnite and last but certainly not
least pubg
the champ champs here baby rocky has
actually held multiple guinness world
records including most victory royales
and fortnite using a quad stick mouth
operated joystick and most eliminations
in a fortnight battle royale using a
quad stick mouth operated joystick rocky
is currently grinding apex for about
three hours a day and then he'll hop on
stream and complete elden ring with no
armor or magic lighter sleep tight
[ __ ] rocky mentions in his
twitch bio that his goal is to spread
disabled gamer awareness as of late
disability in gaming has been somewhat
of a focus for developers some of you
may remember when the last of us part 2
came out and was praised for its
accessible features for players and
twitch itself has been attempting to
address accessibility issues in recent
years last year twitch had come under
fire for discoverability and lack of
captioning on the platform since then
twitch has celebrated global
accessibility awareness day on may 20th
every year twitch has also included tags
for different disabilities when
searching for streamers it's a start but
there's always work to be done when
meeting accessibility needs according to
steve spone senior director of
ablegamers the great part about twitch
is that if you're disabled you get to
watch not only other disabled people
play but able-bodied people and see how
they navigate a game and what they do
you can kind of get a better feel for
whether or not you might have a chance
at adapting it to your needs websites
like can i play that have been created
and are dedicated to reviewing games and
letting gamers know just how accessible
or inaccessible they are it's important
to note that not all disabilities are
physical or visible games might not
accommodate any or all disabilities so
outside solutions are created like
rocky's quad stick rocky told me he's
incredibly grateful for what his twitch
career has brought him and that he hopes
his dream can inspire others i got a
hobby got a career um
and i got a whole bunch of friends and a
whole bunch of stuff to do and you know
it feels good uh
you know when you post a video and
everyone
you know is praising you it feels good
rather than uh you know posting a video
and you get no views or people are all
you know hating on you so i'm enjoying
it and i'm having fun and hopefully
everyone gets something out of it and if
you find yourself on the opposite end of
rocky's gun all i can say is
good luck
nice
lately rocky has been in the news after
he hit diamond 3 and apex legends which
makes sense because apex legends is
literally one of the most technically
demanding games out there
i suck at it i'm terrible at it i cannot
play this game i play lifeline i don't
even know how to put down my little
thing